and now gems with Jim be for you
slipping to bar
and little girl you take my hair all
right ah Jim worse the rest of the band
no doors no music man what's with the
feather I'm tickling the feet of the
Ancient Ones all right Loch Ness
monsters at the pulpits of the great
tenors many times folded up the laundry
before the ocean of the knowledge of
truth oh you are the soul of the
revolution i'm not talking about
destruction I'm talking about Funyuns
bugles Doritos snacks snacks snacks
dehydrated fruit man that's the trip
that I'm on yeah all right is everybody
in is everybody in slip on in to banana
land yeah
I
only three men seldom from the San
Francisco Bay rolled up a bit [ __ ] and
here's what they had to say we're
rolling lazy gentlemen are we rolling
hey man oh yeah we're doing all hung up
on us I just gotta say one thing dislike
riding a bike or blowing glass
marionettes they're easy to use go down
to your local grocer and get one today
it's almost the holidays and we want
everybody to come back to marionettes
gym makers is it Jim Baker's marionette
show they're on a second as you go down
second street past echo park or whatever
there it's you can go see the marionette
show there it's very popular I went
there our kids party yeah really great
glow in the dark Dia de los Muertos
marionettes man Jim minute oh this jim
baker or Bob Baker Bob Baker's
marionette Paula cater right there on
section evangelist I think you guys Jim
Baker had his Merry nuts in that outdoor
dog house with the air conditioning
sorry huge difference oh man yeah big
difference cuz the gym bake I've seen
the Jim Baker marionette show at the
cemetery have you seen that one no I
missed that one they did eat just it's
just like a Punch and Judy thing except
you're the victim until you just fill
the wish plate or whatever what's the
plate call that a pats around it to your
collection plate Bob that's all it's
called it's called the collection plate
is come give me your damn money so God
will like you more plate oh that's what
math that makes more sense a good name
for that plate you want God to like you
more drop a few coins in here under dog
lick ether that's the plate they pass
around the synagogue except that plates
call don't put any dairy on that yeah so
if you don't have any money just spill
some yogurt in there no it's one way of
getting out of it at the old temple
emanuel there on Arguello street in san
francisco that must have happened quite
a bit and I've been to that temple and
and that's the only temple where they
have the indoor bumper cars and the
ceiling is metal so one time when my
wife was being bludgeoned to death by
her
mom's boyfriend yeah and he pulls out
the Bible he'd never met me before and
he's having to hey let's meet Bob and
I'm in Toronto and there's no way out
because it's a long way from home right
yeah he pulls out the Bible and he's
reading a passage about how women should
serve man and we go down to the
marketplace and we pick out what we want
it's a cookbook so that's what I think
that's what it was man it was the
Pillsbury Jesus book or something like
that yeah Pillsbury Jesus I when Lord
and Savior profit you know papa fresh
came out recently that was molested when
he was uh and he was just a little dough
no piece of got a little piece of dough
he's not as fresh as he was no pop pop
yeah he shouldn't have been white just
like a wedding dress that's soiled by a
woman that isn't a virgin I saw it I was
looking for so i soiled he's it's great
to have you I'm gonna do I'm gonna
introduce my guest here in a second but
it's great to have you because it's
great to be here a lot of times i blank
out and soiled that's all I was with a
lil ass oiled little biscuit it wasn't
his fault Pillsbury's knocking indoor
saturday well you're not gonna call
it'll pop it fresh soil little biscuit
so a little biscuit it's just like a
lunchable or or a dinner biscuit that's
it man hmm but nobody's gonna come out
with swords little biscuits are you
gonna hide that secret that no yeah
there's like three layers to the dough
before it pops and somebody played with
his third layer before a pop and he's
ashamed of that Hades yeah he's a soil
biscuit they gotta come out with the
transgender poppin fresh boy girl no I'm
a woman now my name's Caitlin I don't
like this new trend gender pastry it's
confusing my digestive tracts and this
is banana letter did i did i mention
that yet i know i haven't ladies and
gentlemen welcome to banana land with
steve Mahan arosen field hammer Hammer
hammer and my special guest Carlos Alice
rocky Thank You Wow pronounce correctly
that startled me we just just know we've
got the man of a thousand voices yeah
thousand voices that's what I do what's
up [ __ ] yes mr. white yes hahaha I'm
talking about what who's that Aaron Paul
pitch oh it's good very good
is that oh it's good i don't know who it
is but it's good sounds good yo ya'll
good you got a gift why would you make
fun of the co-host the hammer he's gonna
hammer you the quarter call ya carlos
has a knack of making everything so i
don't think there's anything wrong with
explaining the impressions and I the
show back that much no no no who is this
Louie Armstrong yeah CP either heaven
every impression rewind we are sorry my
grandma wasn't either got it said one
small step for man one giant leap for
mankind wait a minute I got those two
mixed up wrong trouble and Chong ATA's
bike step down on that moon with your
dad you're writing a classic is about to
follow it's jamehl Oh Louis Armstrong in
his greatest spaceheadz I'm hitting a
golf ball on the moon a Mars [ __ ] you
hours very long I'm hitting it soon look
uh oh what a notice i chimed in with the
one impression i do so all right good i
figured i sent you up I'm service I
figured the man of a thousand voices
would come across the one and freb then
I did you know the New York Times Lou
called me man of one face man one face I
thoughts positive regattas better thing
than man of two faces any color class
check-in walk wha hey guy home he call
him mayor of one face he is an honest
fellow man of one face he will never be
a Batman character because they need
require more than one face as you know
two faces a character I have to explain
the joke much like Steve header no no I
got it yeah you got it too I got it you
got it let's just go on he will never be
I'll do this akkad acidity but he will
never enjoy a career in the theater ah
that's nice that you will never be cause
that although the one face man Horner
going in of one place man of one face I
have one voice called dancing with cub
one boys let's get together I know
you're going dear void I think I know
what it's gonna be going I get ready for
it yep
hey guys how you doing beautiful man of
wine hoarsely done man of one I worked
on that all night man up one voice and
all sound nebulous you're up all night I
love that word I converted Solemnis I'm
nebulous i converted rise Roger did rise
rot I never went to sleep some ambulance
to me I know what it means but it I just
picture uh Houdini up there making a
woman float the secret early I know what
you're gonna say early Houdini early
Houdini yeah one of the early funny
Houdini when his name was Bob yeah it
wasn't it wasn't they needed a
two-syllable Dana may not various Bob
Houdini everybody I've got one of those
rare posters of babu ditches though hey
not bad Bob Houdini you've got an
underwater dunking tank in your ear hey
hey watch me hang upside down in this
metal pot Oh cone off high school I said
let me have it right come on that's good
I got two voices oh I got one face baby
and two voices one place underwater I
blew out my voice at the Laughing Man
which was uh Van Allen's first outdoor
music festival yeah and we had wait I
guess some of the I've got to thank some
of it uh I've got to thank some of the
sponsors that were with us for the thing
but we had system of a clown and the Red
Hot Chili Peppers has hi Michelle nine
inch snuggie and of course AC he and I
love them this is weird man also
sponsored of course my mother duster
shed tater and our new sponsor Earth
Wind & tire we put the soul back in your
role now what's interesting celebrate
good tires come on yeah it was a
four-day event where we promised two
days worth of entertainment yeah and I
always out there freezing my ass off and
you know I hammer and I were out there
hammer used to microphone which were
smart I didn't use the mic so a little
of ya problem with the voice right now
but uh listen we had three stages yeah
and the third stage the first one is
denial
that's what anger anger the second stage
separated at an altitude of 10,000 feet
well and we've got a big lawsuit going
on there because we killed at least I
don't know Justin David girl didn't fall
off that stage hey I'll tell you hey
thank God they need hey hey that's good
one of these things is not like the
other hey David you're in heaven it's me
yes God is a Jew go figure go figure God
is it you got his you we had three
stages and the third stage it was
supposed to be the least popular stadium
turns out you know you can't figure on
things like that you can't figure on
things it was the most popular one of
them on it was the smallest stage but it
was the most wall attended by the event
and what we had there let me see I've
got a list here who'd you have huge
piles of soft colorful blankets a
Cabbage Patch smallpox free smallpox
free good none of them army issued there
you go a Cabbage Patch with little baby
bunnies running around haha a slideshow
of your mom taking care of you Oh
beautiful flowers landscaped in the
shape of your favorite grade school
teacher so uh french fries diving into
tubs of ketchup and little puppy dogs
running through the crowd handing out
apple juice and mac and cheese oh so
good so that was the that became the
actual Red Cross area that's where
everybody went it was freaking out on
the Special K yeah and uh hi there Molly
and the no I ate too much acid and yeah
things like that and I'll tell you what
man the most well-attended stage that'll
bring you back man I think of it I think
if you could bring stage three to Syria
that would write all the problems that
are going on there named puppies hanging
out mac and cheese I forgive you Assad
there are puppies with Mike and cheese
stage 3 Syria that was it that was it
the Dustin Hoffman movie that nobody saw
that yeah
I don't all doesn't happen bangles baby
ah I am a woman dr. Brewster silly oh
wait do you not wanna get high you mark
my oyster I'm appreciate that I'll be
Fierstein no was he in that movie yeah I
wasn't he Bill Murray's friends and some
no army wasn't in that movie you're
thinking of clothes oh so Marilla
concept mrs. Doubtfire mrs. Doubtfire oh
honey yeah I do it that house alabi
Harvey was also in the independence day
yeah you're right he was he had his son
was gonna save the world so that way he
got saved too there you go I'll get on
the boat no that was a 2012 really got
on the boat the big arc with John prozac
was a limo driver not to be confused
with San Andreas Fault when you know I
just watched 2012 the other dates we
related it's weird that you brought that
up man because I'll what I'll do is I'll
put on a sleeper movie don't really I
don't know why that got into the sleeper
category cuz I have you know the
tinnitus so a little white noise or a
bedtime story yeah now I used to watch
what was great was uh goodnight moon
goodnight moon yeah that's a great one
for your kids cuz it's short cuz you're
really freaking tired and you want your
kids are go to bed goodnight moon I'll
let you check that out um well the oh uh
Braveheart was it good oh yeah the great
score and a lot of narration not a
narration fighting you day made I run
away and you live at least a while and
dining in your beds many years from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this date to that for one
chance one chance to come back here
again and tell your enemies that they
can take it lies but they can never take
your freedom that's the speech that's
the speech and what would you give what
that's what i did i had that speech
memorized i said these are my two
favorite movies and it goes like this I
don't know if I could do the whole
speech ever say yeah and what would you
give to trade all of those days from
this one to that to come back and tell
your enemies that they may take your
life but they may never take your new
phone book
here the new phone monkey's hand it's a
matter of course was the Braveheart in
the jerk Braveheart your head turns out
he was one yeah the Nazi plates yeah but
sugar tits all isn't yeah he was a jerk
he was no I saw about that I havana club
didn't up berkeley not berkeley Beverly
Hills how do I get those who too
confused haha you're hanging out with a
melkco I was very bad him and him by not
at didn't Beverly Hills but not it
matter we had steely blue eyes you met
yeah I did Mel Gibson was he lying to be
no right fella you know seem to be but
you're not Jewish I am NOT Jewish
actually I'm last developers your safari
at you Sephardic but i'm not a
participating for your name a Sephardic
Sephardic Ella's rocky is a Spain Turkey
France Argentina Spanish sequences and
said hey Alice Rockies converter get the
hell out and they made like Moen said
yeah I studied i stir it like moment
said we getting out of here see i
studied my wiki that's why I knew that
your last name was Sephardic that's
right mmm oh no did you what are we
talking about Oh Mel Gibson Mel Gibson
he told me he wasn't frightened me so
what late you met him at the I met him
at the havana club in beverly hills
where's that that's right there on the
corner that the kardashian and what the
[ __ ] oh they must go uneaten canyon or
something like that Bosco and um yeah
yeah yeahs Dayton Canaan they can't
cannula or something like that right
there in a corner oh don't know it don't
know I've been there several times and
now wait a minute you've never been at
havana club hammer I suppose does know
well I'm taking you hey Bob's got his
own personal humidor there you can go
that you can obscure good sense of humor
door you could see ya scratch that off
your bucket list baby yeah I'll kick the
doors down i'll take you there i'll have
to put it on my bucket low we can always
stay yeah oh we can only stay for my
guest 30 seconds but I yeah I'm person
wrong I'm Tyler I'd like to be seated at
mels table please
hey so the havana club is a cigar yeah
Arnold Schwarzenegger has a humidor
there too that's right there it's right
on the thing it's by the tasers on the
door yes and all these kinds of things
and cigars and things and might have you
met him I leave my watermelon mistress
sleeps in the box there so when I need I
pull out the box i make a kid in the
night throw back in with the cigars
Arnold lives in his yes you know in this
humidor yeah that's gotta be a it's a
humvee humidor now that's probably a
hell of a membership fee right there
right oh yeah 16 or do you have a my
friend does my friend a Jeff Valdez has
a membership there and yes L he has a
humidor there at the Ivana club as the
Latinos would say I remember Jeff Valdez
is everyone I'm thinking of it must be a
frenzy for ma technically thing colorado
yeah colorado springs colorado I know
yep I haven't seen him in a long time
well he must be doing all right all
right he's got his own humidor he's got
his own not many Mexicans have their own
humidor let me say no that's not true
that's true not anymore yeah not just a
Latin comedy explosion you know that
that's right Rhiana are you part of that
I was part of that you let an explosion
yeah mmm see cuz I can go anywhere I can
you know my person from Argentina I got
a Jewish last name a spanish first name
I can go anywhere I want I was Amara
video to Billy comedy explosion Billy
only 30 people showed up yeah you know
i'll be there were good crowd I'm not
gonna knock him you know Jeff Arnstein
you know you're a Jew in and kinky
friedman did you see me Freeman the
jewish covered what did you is cowboy my
rosetta yeah he was a country singer
well there you go another went well no
no kinky friedman was uh he had a clay
was a club promoter he was a club
promoter yeah kicky free air it was a
singer in the seventies yeah it was yeah
kinky friedman is texas few boys we were
doing so well that he had we're doing so
well now everybody's Google and kinky
friedman yeah well if you I'm not when
you come back now all the listeners are
Google and kinky there's TV Friedman she
was a hell of a stripper tell you that
my voice will come without trial come
back
we need Carlos here every week I'll be
here every week ladies gentlemen Rod
Stewart yeah i'm going to Maggie stay
with me ball tonight you're gonna stay
with me yeah get down your voice is too
good to be right that's very good hey
with me uh uh yeah uh yeah you're right
not to be confused with Rod Serling stay
with me tonight you're going to Maggie I
couldn't have tried any harder that's
Johnny Carson riders or any Carson that
is John easterly chonies sterling that's
you know Johnny's favor guess was a
Midwest Cal huh ladies gentlemen uh uh
Jo Jo Starbuck that was his favorite
lady had her on just the icing hater
married dude well Terry Bradshaw yeah
listen I know she was on last night but
I love saying her name please welcome Jo
Jo Starbuck and now there's one on every
corner yep yep they tell me your car on
roller skates and deliver coffee Jojo
starbucks dojo starbucks starbucks oh
yeah Jojo that was uh she was the first
wife of Terry Bradshaw yeah you're right
we know he's not know that that you do
not I do not know that and I said
rosenfield drew drew sure by now Carlos
Bob sleeve you are our second official
guest here on banana whoa Jake Johansen
well Jake Johansen from Iowa yeah and
you are second or third is going to be
John Cleese let the hold the front door
well I can I go shut it hold it follow
you man I gotta have John Cleese now
each up please jerk please yeah some
faulty yes and now here are the latest
soccer scores yeah a raging fire
thoroughly overwhelmed an empty bottle
of scotch 322 you don't betting on the
horses again are you bezel know my
lovely piranha fish that Avenue a
pleasure has been closed off from my
life Fawlty Towers baby yeah man that
was awesome i met john cleese I didn't
meet him and say hello cuz I went to
some voiceover on the west side near
bundy and olympic and I runs late and I
was like drunk please I met his daughter
at the cobo Comedy Festival two years
ago very tall blonde girl
John Cleese's daughter yep hey um we're
gonna wrap things up I got I know yeah I
know that you got to go do a major
you're filming tonight on your major
motion picture major motion picture yep
okay yeah I got I got a well actually to
say I really Torre will tell you where
I'm telling her well yeah I mean if you
want to be honest I'm not I'm not
filming a major motion picture I'm doing
another podcast and it's what it's it's
it's just a small thing it's uh it's
matt damon Matt Damon's podcast it's
what wake the [ __ ] up Boston I think
it's called back no it's really I'm just
kidding i'm actually doing Matt Damon's
podcast I'm like all right yeah sorry aw
schedule yeah I've known you for ya 30
years but if you gotta go do a podcast I
get it you guys are all right but you're
no Matt Damon's but I gotta go all right
thanks Carlos thanks 560 appreciate you
coming by that was a firm handshake
alright see you guys later well that was
amazing man that guy is incredible he's
so funny uh Carlos I was rocky everybody
that was Carlos I was rocky and yeah
sure let's give him let's give a hand
out our absolutely incredible huh yeah
Carlos he won the comedy competition in
San Francisco and then he yeah yeah and
indie and then he came down to Hollywood
to buy a comic book and ended up booking
a cartoon he was in Hollywood for like
he was in Hollywood for like 30 minutes
oh look at this ladies and gentlemen
unbelievable holy cow is Roger lawyers
it's him Roger Waters raw from pitchfork
Oh fine Katie thank you so much [ __ ] spit
to see Roger the hammer rights mmm
everybody Roger it's amazing it
wonderful to be here as well yes yeah
it's amazing to see you it's amazing to
see you again my friend you look
wonderful I feel wonderful I feel are
sorry I'm late there was a wall of
traffic no no you did
unrehearsed so oh yes Roger I've been
reading that you got back in the studio
I'm back in studio yes is true the back
in yeah okay you want to tell us what's
going on I don't wanna actually I'm not
sure for what if I read was was true or
not much like the Constitution and some
albums were made to be amended and I
might have made some changes to some
classic songs from from the album's
we've done the wall wish you were here
from dark side and I wanted to announce
for the first time on your podcast was
with such good friends I wanted to also
say that a lot of people thought that
the inspiration for dark side was syd
barrett and his lunacy and things like
that but is actually the inspiration was
Bob I was hanging out fifth in clemente
san francisco in the late 80s and i know
you think that the album the wall was
before that but it wasn't real happen
you don't know what's happening you
don't eat a time thing and i saw Bob
Rubin and I thought I'm gonna write the
lunatic is in my brain and lot of people
think that's about Syd Barrett it's
about even Roger yeah that's beautiful
yes what does this say that I wish my
mom was alive to hear that well she
didn't get it she is that's the surprise
that you don't know about does she get
it she gets it back everybody but yeah I
am here to to let everybody know for the
first time I've made some significant
changes to some classic songs amazing
and this is exclusive yet very exclaims
to banana land and the our listeners and
your listener so if you know I would
recommend being in a seated position to
hear these changes because prized there
instrumental no pollen talent and their
monster monstre mental is what i want
and very yeah I'm excited that a word
I'm monster waters I will yes my new
album is called monstre mental monster
mental only a genius like yourself could
fuse those two words together I know a
guy that took synergy and ingenuity and
and
and he came up with the word sin genuity
since you know but he's not a genius no
he's not he site but you know what but
now i'm glad i'm sitting down i'm about
to you can i sell with excitement if
you're about to be blown away and you
brought you brought wrong with me
alright and you set this up with earlier
with uh we did our engineer Jimmy Lee
yes we saw some action on you like a
magician doing a miracle actually have
met before good good but you are going
to be just a melee pool actually our
engineer know is youthful Erin hello
youthful Erin Timmy's our tech guru when
I've got something special like this and
apparently this is amazing so I want to
preface it by saying if you are fans of
these classic songs you won't be
offended at the changes but you will be
blown away if that makes sense but uh
let's let's hear one alright alright and
it is an honor to be doing this with you
that's they were you Lauren
Oh
oh wow didn't that is unbelievable yes
oh my did you hear that yes yeah that is
it credible I don't Roger I gotta admit
something first of all you just blew my
mind for the nine million get Julia time
fine case all right to the tenth degree
now I'm not exactly sure what you did
there well when I was saying we don't
need no education what I didn't realize
is that i did and i could be educated
and making some significant changes now
I had studied dogs not like son of sam i
had actually watched dogs and various
sounds like blown away the movie with
John Travolta and of course bridges
courts are where he's a sound guy one of
those movies um and so I started
experimenting with sound and changes and
as you heard in that song so that is
that I don't correct me if I'm wrong but
was that a slide whistle did you put in
there you got me it's a slide way so I
I'm always lonely my love clowns I love
sly whistles I love slapstick and I
thought and of course stunning with the
of that sound the dogs and how they
respond right what it's supposed to
represent is a slip off the wall Oh onto
the head cracking the head open Wow and
kind of like you're like you're a Humpty
Dumpty era yeah in a way yes way right
if I mean no no the horses men could
ever fix me no Roger no I did nothing
you're not broken well I you're with
your god damn can we earn another one
have more on this again wonderful subtle
change to another Floyd classic and I
think you're gonna like this one
unbelievable
do you know if I suddenly feel happy I
don't know why and why what that
represents again the slide whistle and I
confess it's two for two is that is the
slide and the funniness of the corporate
sliding from our lives you know it used
to be so representative of what we were
going through and I decided what if I
just suck the energy from corporations
right out it's as if the air was being
let go of the pig what was floating over
the bill is a car factory the only way
to escape what we've been trapped inside
of is by complete accident yet to make
slapstick fun of the corporations like
you're silly so that's classic got like
a be harping absolutely infiltrate yeah
and then make the changes and then makes
you our boys do that and then boom it's
from like the inside out right yeah
absolutely inside out from the side from
the left from diagonal and and and this
if I've not got one more one more okay
we'll talk we'll talk about that the
collective yeah changes of all three
songs okay why more this is gonna be
this is all so it's it's a little bit
different than what we've been you'll
see
I mean you see there i'm taking it to
them I added them the vibrato haha which
I did on my own make her the time with
you thank you with I have my invisalign
sand so it doesn't sound as crisp as it
did wow those are what that represents
it's like I'm through with her and I
she's right out the door and she's not
coming back does that that's got like
corkscrewing out it's causing because it
without that slide whistle there's a
possibility of the listener thinking
that in that song that she's coming back
to me but means that is over okay so
like good food right doing that what
you've done is there's no way that she
could just not likely come back you know
she couldn't retrace yeah she couldn't
retrace she could retreat that then that
would be impossible but if you did a
linear movement that most people would
do and that is like I'm done with you
and I walk away that's a strange looks
like it's like I'm not a straight line
man let's know what that is is a musical
Molly bolt that when you screw it in you
can't get it out I'm just gonna push it
just kind of opens up and that's it yeah
that's it you could call it a buddy
holly bolt if you want this another joke
just you could call Gary Hoey boat they
won't don't die on a plane though like
much existed i'm sorry apologized but
got that all joke right there and
they'll Molly by this like I'm still
thinking about the the the passage away
from that woman and she she can't come
back and uh that's almost that kind of
traveling would take you to another
dimension which is what your music does
she's like the alien at the end of alien
that Sigourney Weaver's character just
right up in space so I know if you sink
those movies up like dark side and and
and Wizard of Oz as you know if you sync
up that with Sigourney jetta Singh the
alien off it's perfectly synchronized in
all Genuity is what it is is it right to
coin a world that your friend yeah now
there there it is i believe his word
genius he's just got 5,000 hits on
twitter immediately just from that
reference now you know what people are
doing now I
haven't done this because I'm like I
don't want to get into this I'm not
gonna ruin I excuse my bad pun my mother
water down Rogers music when people are
seeking up they're not gonna waters tell
me Gilmore this what I would say he's a
punt and Gilmore right I would not you
know people are seeking up Dark Side of
the Moon many professor now the yeah not
that one from 1960 yes the one that
there what's his name did Eddie Murphy
right breathe breathe here I may I could
eat this stuff see ya it cut it kind of
a guy I would have sunk in alum what's
the first one yeah oh yeah lady without
hey if you can do that I would have just
go to her breath one day closer to death
I've all got so you've returned your
books open and Wisel like I evade
absolutely brilliant oh I'm shocked and
not shocked yeah your own brilliance
like has been there and you've been
spreading it out yeah like sunshine well
again moonlight I will ania all over the
world for such a long time so I have
these new changes are going to be it's
like monstre mental as I've calling that
were there going to be a monster mental
and I think it might hisana of course we
lost our keyboard player several years
ago he passed um he went and you know
about like the woman yeah so we just
might launch a new tour really fun
exciting that the fans would love to see
this long that's excited what what we're
doing right now is synchronizing a light
show to the sound that's you got to take
a live artist I like the way alive we're
gonna take in a travel to add to that
portal I in the sky but to cry think I
might call the new to a portal in the
sky tour let's examine you and why they
when you buy the ticket you can actually
shake it in the ticket all go that's not
very brand-new yeah when I was a kid and
they would have it
either in the cereal or the cracker jack
yep that ring the PF PF flyer tennis
sneakers tennis shoes when I was a yeah
yeah and those and PF flyer run faster
jump higher jump on and you wanna take
you to another portal right because I
was sort of musically stuck in the
quicksand because I did not have my
musical PF flyers and then I thought
I've got to do something different I've
gotta add slide whistle and then you're
the one I know that you weren't involved
involved directly but with cinnamon
toast at Applejack's you have you had
your hand in that too also yes I was I
was stowed away in the proverbial
honeycomb house three fort when I when I
came up with the cinnamon absolutely
CIO's incredible and again Applejack
sorry yeah and again taking people at a
very young age to a new portal so they
could see really broaden their vision
right and that's what I think you've
always done I've always tell you know
the other thing is that people a lot of
people the music industry may be either
after your brilliant body of work which
is really uncomfortable but other people
when they've worked for decades and
they've produced albums and though um
they'll either spend all their time
thinking of their next album or they
retire and you have done neither and
you've still and look what you've done
by focusing on music that was already
brilliant you figured out a way to take
it to another level not if people think
that you need to go into the future to
make changes and I've gone back to
classic slapstick slide whistle and
brought two generations together now
that previously will not together much
like Donald Trump is doing and to make
America great I'm trying to make music
great Mary there he goes again only uh
you know this time he's being
politically astute yeah unbelievable
Roger now I gotta ask you something if
um if there is a tour yes where do you
think you would announce that stage
three of your outdoor concert where you
just lost your voice so that could have
a next year unbelievable a story with
the puppies in the macaroni
kraft cheese I love the shoe at you
which you would make an appearance at
laughing man absolutely well there you
heard it dirty there you have it lazy
gentlemen Roger Roger that as I say well
Roger over and out i guess uh that's
right 10-4 let's say say 10-4 yes uh I
need backup yeah right sometimes say
that officer down to 12 yeah I officer
Downton Abbey is what we say miss J do
haha officer don't Navi that's right yes
and I just want to say that thank you
for coming by with I want to thank you
for this is gonna be available this
would be available in 2091 2091
everybody worth waiting for absolutely
not a long time not alone not a long
time Roger will be the first guy to tell
you time is a man-made concept well now
I'll be the second guy to tell you that
because you're the first guy to tell
that you were the first guy one of the
first but guess what I public healing
but privately I was but now publicly you
re first probably I'm number one Papa I
was trying to give you credit for sale
right the first guy to sand it might
have come off as you said I yes right
kind of usurped that and pushed you to
the second guy but know what I was
saying in fact within you were the first
guy to say that right I'm saying that
publicly the normal say I was the first
guy to write it you know you're right
but david gilmour actually sang it but i
was the writer he was the singer but you
were the first guy to say it and that
was the inspiration for him to write the
song absolutely but at a time neither
one of you were in public no we were not
in public we were in one of those Gump
construction porta-potties well that's
incredible we would yes and listen I
want to thank you for God wanna thank
you absolutely amazing thank you the
hammer nice to meet you as well I didn't
but how mr. Raja me thank you for being
brilliant Thank You Jimmy now azuz
excellent job you say hi to pink for me
I could have a hair clip pink we're
doing a mash-up comedy to it's called
pink floyd the barber the character from
andy griffith absolutely and it goes a
little something
oh there is no pain you are receding oh
I've become comfortably numb Andy so I
item crying him the lyrics of my music
and put it to Floyd the barber well we
can't wait to see that yeah it's gonna
be fantastic it certainly is Roger
Waters everybody and you'll see the
homeland Thank You Roger he's a nice guy
you know he sure is we'll be right back
and now ladies and gentlemen it's time
to play everybody's favorite game fast
550 this is the game where if you
haven't listened to banana land before
this is a game where I play with the
hammer and this is where I ask the
hammer a series of 550 questions and you
just answer them off the top of your
head fast 550 here we go you ready yes
pot stickers are sly stone sly stone
black patty or give your dog a bone give
your dog a bone cold pizza or impending
doom impending doom favorites sleeping
position sideways no that's false the
first one was founded in 1843 true or
false appetite is a Greek word meeting
flavor false no that's true it was
organized by farmers to ensure fair crop
prices I was so close so anyhow okay
here we got it we got another one
sleeping sleeping in or huffing huffing
whoa I am such a dork what happened I
apologize uh the Matt Damon podcast is
tomorrow
Wow so I'm all right Betsy movies
podcast kind of missed it by this is
kind of uh yeah I'm we're glad you're
back you didn't miss much no unless
you're in the pig Floyd you like pink
floyd at all yes well Roger Waters was
just in here oh and he he and he was
here especially for the first time
preview he took three of his classics
and he previewed it for our audience he
did remixes with him ah he did another
brick in the wall reebok he did welcome
to the machine remix ah and he did young
lust remix was a flamenco I'm not gonna
tell you wait till 29 10 I have nobody
well I can go back and listen to this
podcast though and then I'll be able to
hear it yeah you could do that is well
that'd be cheating though yeah you could
do that or I'm just bummed you just got
to make sure that you know what day
you're going to meet a giant movie star
to do his podcast I didn't know no it
wouldn't happened but uh no I don't know
I I understand stuff like that happens
all time you know what Roger might be
coming back yeah all right no you might
not as yes sir he might but yeah sure
we've got stricter regulations
broadcasting all that here under and
we're out of time all right though I
just want to say hammer yes thanks for
being here thank you for having youth
Lehren Thank You Jimmy Lee Jimmy Lee our
tech Britta audience Carlos yeah I was
rocky I'm Hannah absolutely incredible
let me ask you quick even if Roger
Waters doesn't come back will you
absolutely i'll be back that's what I
wanted to hear good bye everybody bye
bye
a banana land Robin interview I'm
sitting here with Carlos Alice rocky yes
I've shown my serious voice sir I don't
like I was on the the the actors that'd
be voice number theory for you oh holy
cow I'm kicking out see how you inspire
people I do it it's like the Steelers
can only beat play with the good teams
they can't beat the bad one that can't
beat the bad ones uh but you think
everybody's game up I pick everybody's
game out arise you to a new level now
Carlos lies my son Carlos Alice rocky
has had an incredible career and I've
known you for a long time and we both
came out of all three of us to come from
the San Francisco yeah comedy scene at
one point or another let's start out for
a second you won the Comedy Competition
93 I believe I think it was a year after
dawn McMillan and her Johnny steal one I
think was down McMillan one and then i
won that's great company that's the san
francisco international comedy that's
right international and then you moved
to uh did you move to Hollywood or were
you already living here when you didn't
know III got rocko's modern life in 91
and then found out it was going to
series in 92 and then I won the
competition in 93 and I did the old
thing that he needed you to do in packed
up my bags and move to the valley in 94
January 94 set up my apartment all nice
and neat leave that weekend that was the
big earthquake come back had to redo my
apartment but that's when I moved 94 I
want to talk about some of the recent
stuff you've done yeah but carlos has
you've got some mind-boggling skills and
talent that is obvious but still the
thing is East he was doing stand-up for
three weeks and he wins the
international common country then he
goes to hollywood to pick up your you
came you were going to that comic book
store burbank right people were handing
out flyers for an audition for know the
raucous mock Rocko's Modern Life
actually happened in San Francisco
guiding George my s3 live underneath the
Sutro towers not directly but up on the
hill there and there was uh mark
McNamara was a professor at SF State
Tracy Forrester Hayden now numark uh was
doing a cartoon called Rocko's Modern
Life Jomarie a San Jose Mercury
cartoonists how created this thing and I
came in didn't have an agent audition
with a bunch of guys and
I did his little voice I did she stay oh
oh gosh I did spot spunky spunky and
they like incredible and then I got the
part and then I move like I said in
93-94 so it was in San Francisco I
didn't know what I was doing thank you
for being here really appreciate it man
I appreciate being appreciate this is a
spectacular spectacular banana land and
now we hope to see in banana and again
follow me on twitter at boise on the
rocky you listen to me on the stephanie
miller a radio podcast show on free
speech org every wednesday morning
coffee with carlos from 732 9am and on
facebook so look for me there okay
ladies and gentlemen the man of a
thousand voices Carlos thanks a lot
thanks Bob Thank wonderful TV a hammer
Thank You Carlos Gonzalez rocky thank
you sir that was a banana land ruffin
interview
he
fish